salue ici le liner targo rock évidemment
j'espère que vous allez bien on se
retrouve pour une vidéo plutôt spécial
puisque c'est le nouveau concept que je
vous proposais c'était que je vous fasse
un sondage et que vous y répondiez et du
coup sûr ce premier sondage c'était en
rapport avec star wars 8 donc vous et
poser dix questions sur star wars 8 et
on va réagir à ce sondage c'est un
concept que vous avez proposé vous avoir
d'être chaud vous avez été énormément à
répondre à ce sondage donc ça me fait
énormément plaisir vous avez vous avez
été plus de 1000 à répondre donc c'est
énorme ça me fait extrêmement plaisir je
vois que vous êtes chaud j'espère que
vous serez encore plus
et si vous voulez participer aux
prochains sondages et basse est déjà
prêt dans la description n'hésitez pas
allez le voir je vous laisse la surprise
de sur quoi ça va être
et puis bon écoutez bon on est parti
donc on va commencer on va réagir alors
premièrement les questions basiques 1
du coup est ce que vous êtes un homme ou
une femme donc qui a 102 masculin 112
femmes
dix personnes qui que ceux qui se
considèrent comme autres entre 16 et 19
ans vous êtes 412 25 ans 121 en ouevre
la plus de 26 ans il y en a quand même
commençons alors du coup la première
question que je vous proposais c'était
avez vous aimé star wars 8
car ça a été un très gros débat eu
beaucoup de critiques
oui star wars 8c de la mer tout ça parce
que ce star wars 8 casse complètement
les codes des autres stars wars n'a pas
eu vraiment de combat de sabre laser ou
autre l'udc a changé j'ai eu plein de
choses voilà donc vous êtes quand même
83% voir mick vous aimiez star wars 8
vous êtes quand même 90 % plus de 90%
93% avoir aimé il a 7 % qui sont
catégoriques
non alors moi je trouve vraiment
intéressant ce star wars parce que
justement on met deux vidéos réaction et
trois théories c'est qu'ils changent
voilà on a évolué
star wars évolué on n'est plus à
l'époque de l' empire on est quand même
bien longtemps après les moeurs ont
changé le tout a changé et l'udc a
compris comment fonctionnait forcée qui
étaient en bas que ça s'arrête pour les
jedi et aussi bas le côté obscur et
c'est pour doit conserver les scènes
avec finn et en rose
alors bien évidemment j'ai pas vu encore
je me suis gardé la surprise de voir vos
réponses parce que c'est vrai que les
scènes avec finn et rose alors finir aux
ce qu'ils font c'est que ils partent en
mission pour essayer de sauver les
rebelles tout ça en cherchant
décrypteurs tout ça pour rentrer dans la
base
impérial sauf qu'au final la mission
échoue et en plus du coup ils font tué
plusieurs rebelles à cause du
décrypteurs là parce qu'il les a trahis
du coup bah c'est potentiellement à
cause de coûts les saynètes fine et rose
potentiellement ne servent à rien dans
l'histoire à savoir votre avis là-dessus
donc il ya quand même six pour cent qui
pensent que ça sert à rien donc le
questionnaire était quand même assez
globale gc j'essayais de proposer
plusieurs propositions un peu au global
on va dire pour pas que ça soit trop
diverses
vous êtes quand même 35 % à penser que
ça fait passer de trois messages d'ordre
humain et écologique
c'est ce que je pense moi aussi parce
qu'il ya eu la cause animale tout ça et
c'est le trafic et l'argent et c'est que
les bons les gentils bas avons quand
même des trafics un petit peu sale en en
achetant des bombes au méchant fin à des
à des gens qui ne pensent qu'à l'argent
tout ça et c'est qu'ils s'en foutent du
monde et je pense que ça a servi à ça
moi personnellement alors il y en a
quand même 16% qu'ont pensé que c'était
pour combler le film il savait pas trop
quoi faire de finir aux du coup voilà à
occuper fine car on ne sait pas quoi en
faire et 26 pour saint qui on pensait ça
alors c'est pas quoi faire de fines très
bien baffin ne sert à rien ce qui est
bien possible
du coup à casser les codes de films
américains j'ai entendu ça parce que
j'ai regardé beaucoup de vidéos réaction
à star wars 8 j'ai trouvé c'était une
chose intéressante voilà parce que c'est
vrai dans les codes de films américains
passent comme la star wars à américain
tout ça les gentils gagnent toujours et
voilà ils font peut-être deux trois
erreurs mais ils réussissent toujours ce
qu'ils font leur but tout ça et là
justement c'est tout le contraire
les gentils au final bas fine ne sert à
rien ce qui fait s'est il a fait une
grosse erreur voilà et puis ça au final
y ait des répercussions des rebelles qui
meurent ils ont fait de la merde
ils ont fait de la merde ils ont fait de
la merde c'est tout ce que j'ai à dire
par contre vous êtes énormément à penser
que c'est pour introduire rose dans la
saga alors moi personnellement rose je
la vois plus comme une personnages
secondaires ou autres pas plus
importante que ça question 3 comment as
tu trouvé le personnage de luke
skywalker dans starwars une basse que
luke skywalker lorsqu'il faut savoir
c'est que mark hamill donc l'acteur de
luke skywalker ne voulait pas jouer ce
type de personnage pour lui qu il était
destiné à faire autre chose à la base à
être plus enthousiastes à et des raies
tout ça mais là le personnage de lucky
et grisonnants vieux cons on va dire
voilà exactement c'est un vieux con on
peut le dire et il voyait pas jouer sa
marque a mis à la base il était un petit
peu perturbé de jouer ça et du coup
c'est vrai que le personnage l'udc n'est
pas le même et il se peut que vous vous
ne m'ayez pas aimer tout ça et du coup
vous êtes 62 8% à trouver que l'udc a
très bien vieilli évolué a pris
conscience de tout ça ça doit enfin ça
devait s'arrêter 15 % 16 % plutôt on
peut dire que vous n'attendiez rien de
spécial pour lui qui est devenu vieux et
voilà c'est dans sa continuité tu
deviens vieux sénile et des cons et
c'est bien qu'ils sont déçus je pensais
qu'il serait toujours optimiste est prêt
à combattre au sabre moi personnellement
je trouve que l'udc a très très bien
vieilli voilà il a évolué il a pris
conscience justement il est parti sur
acto pour justement s'isoler et puis bah
du coup avec sa solitude tout ça il a
pris conscience de certaines choses que
le personnage est tout à fait en accord
avec ce qu il faut et ça faisait un
moment j'en parlais dans mes vidéos
trois théories voilà le jedi ça doit
s'arrêter le côté obscur aussi voilà la
force
c'est eux qui perturbe c'est eux qui
perturbe tout ce qui équilibre et c'est
dans le monde
et du coup à chaque foyer une guerre etc
mais les autres je peux comprendre que
certains soient déçus à ce que lui qui
très optimiste à la base tu final je
trouve que il a très bien vu pour la
prochaine question qui a été votre
réaction facettes et miri blague à la
fin de star wars suite l'enfant qui
apprend avec la france pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas le nom pour ceux qui
n'auraient pas vu mon 3 théorie du coup
il ya plusieurs interprétations pour se
pour ce gosse alors moi à la base la
première fois que je les ai vus gêné je
ne les ai pas vus prendre le ballet avec
la force me suis juste dit voilà c'est
un gamin il content il veut rejoindre la
rébellion
super incroyable et du coup après quand
j'ai revu le film we prend bien le
ballet avec la force et il a l'air
vraiment d'être un symbole et c'est donc
c'est un élu bon c'était un petit peu le
côté troll donc vous êtes quand même 10
% à le penser je pense pas que ce soit
un élu non plus les jedi ne sont pas
encore éteints donc moi c'est ce que je
pensais vous êtes quand même 40 % le
penser que les jedi ne sont pas encore
éteints moi c'est ce que je pensais
aussi s'il sait utiliser la force et que
disney a décidé de le montrer à la
caméra et de montrer qui sait utiliser
la force à la fin comme une sorte de
titres aig tout ça de mise en attente
c'est justement valeur voire se gausse
risque d'avoir un rôle conséquent s'il
sait utiliser la force justement je
repense par exemple hamas kanata maska
nater la base y avait des scènes où on
la voyait utiliser la force pour sauver
aurait ou un truc du genre par exemple
de gravats ou autre elle va choper les
gravats en plein vol les poser à côté
pour la sauver et faire un truc du genre
une connerie comme ça et ces scènes ont
été retirés pour justement l'intriguent
voilà mazal sait utiliser la force
mais ce n'a pas été montré c'est pas
utile aux en soi qu on sait qu elle sait
utiliser la force
c'est pas utile de nous le montrer alors
que l'ajustement terrible agça a été
montré par disney s'était pointé du
doigt s'est mis à la fin pour justement
en plus c'est la dernière scène qu'on
voit donc c'est celle qui va nous rester
le plus en tête et je pense que ce gamin
risque de devenir un jedi un jour et
c'est peut-être possiblement pour la
trilogie du 10 11 12 comme je parlais
dans la vidéo trois théories que ce
gamin quand il sera grand sera le jedi
avec une toute nouvelle histoire tout
seul à loin des skywalker comme il était
prévu dans le cahier des charges de
disney mais beaucoup ont
on penser autre chose et je respecte
votre choix parce que c'est vrai aussi
pour moi c'est qu'il est le symbole du
retour de la résistance et des paroles
de l'ue concernant la force voilà donc
luc fait un petit speech un moment une
sorte de petite morale comme quoi avant
il est devant kyle lorraine ludique la
résistance va revenir qu'elle se reforme
justement que l'espoir est revenue et
que justement ce gamin montre justement
il fait écho aux paroles de l'udc et qu'
il est le retour la résistance il a
d'ailleurs la bague que rose lui a donné
et moi je suis d'accord avec ça aussi
[ __ ] snook ça a été vraiment la grosse
surprise de ce film je ne m'y attendais
pas du tout c'était la dernière chose
auquel j'aurais pensé en voyant star
wars 8 et du coup là on voit aux
réponses que c'est vraiment très très
dispersé donc grosse déception ce
personnage il est mort comme une merde
voilà c'est le plan cartésien voilà il
est mort et c'est 5 nuls voilà il est
mort c'est fini c'est une merde voilà
vous êtes 21% 22% à le penser quand même
vous êtes quand même 13 % à les 12% à ne
pas savoir du tout à moi aussi j'ai un
peu dans ce cas là je ne sais pas du
tout je suis perdu en même temps mon
coeur me dit que moi il n'est pas mort
vous êtes quand même 25 % en france et
il n'est pas mort il va revenir il est
le suprême leader en même temps ce nom
qu il est montré comme quelqu'un de sage
et de puissants et il se fait avoir
très bêtement parquet lorraine et c'est
déjà fait battre par ray y perd
facilement alors qu'elle ne maîtrisait à
rien de la force et en plus il a snow
qui est le suprême leader qui tac ça
dégage ils maîtrisent révoit la chute du
avec une simplicité incroyable
du coup c'est vraiment une grosse
question même moi je suis totalement
perdue je suis incapable de vous donner
une réponse là dessus bon et toi qu'en
penses-tu fine fini me dis qu'ils
pensent que c'est les 26 % restants argo
rock me fait douter sur sa mort à cause
de 103 théorie et c'est là où je suis
content c'est là où je suis content
parce que mes trois théories sont là
pour vous faire douter vous transmettre
de l'émotion de epic n'est ce qui est
des petits frissons parfois que vous
réfléchissiez que ça vous donne encore
plus envie d'aimer la saga du coup c'est
pour ça que je mets trois théories ses
moyens mais j'avais ma braguette ouverte
super question si j'étais obligé de la
mède parce que gersois mais plein de
commentaires à propos de la dessus je
comprends pas pourquoi
du coup je me suis dit il faut que je
mette une question croyez-vous à la
théorie de snacks égale mail window non
pas du tout à 87% et c'est ce qui me
rassure
mais vous êtes quand même 13 % donc 132
sur 1000 à dire oui mais swing d'ô bon
d'accord c'était un très grand jada il
était au même titre que yoda c'est à
dire chef tout ça de la république fin
de l'ordre jedi il était leader avec
yoda il avait son sabre violée il était
unique et cetera
c'est comme ça il est quand même mort
dignement windu est mort face à
l'empereur palpatine qui n'est quand
même pas rien et puis en plus il est
mort aussi à cause de anakin qui tout de
même l'élu et le futur dark vador donc
c'est quand même pas personne ces deux
personnages c'est quand même des
personnages vraiment très très très très
puissant et windu qui est très très très
très puissant aussi bas voilà il s'est
fait avoir de contraindre une situation
difficile de traîtrise où il faisait
confiance à anakin et il est mort voilà
il se fait couper les il se fait couper
le bras il se fait électrocuter voilà
les éclairs de la force de palpatine qui
sont quand même tout de même assez
puissant et il serait propulsée par la
fenêtre et puis voilà il est mort les
parents devraient donc les parents de ré
séparer attendez je vois un petit coup
de café la scène allait vraiment
compliqué tout ça et c'est donc après je
sais qu'il ya trois théories qui vous a
influencé un petit peu aussi pour
certains c'est bien possible
donc vous êtes 32 à penser que les
parents de ré sont de simples faire
ailleurs
mais mais qu'on ne nous a pas tout dit
je ne pense pas du tout que ça soit ça
faisait comme un tiers à penser ça
quasiment tout simplement parce que
c'est un vaisseau en fait qu'ils
abandonneraient en fait le vaisseau il
abandonnerait alors parce tu cotises
toute ta vie mais bon sur le jacquouille
a pas vraiment moyen d'avoir la thune et
avoir un vaisseau tu es plutôt pie ix
pilleurs puis use d'épaves comme vrai et
c'est le seul business que tu peux faire
sur jack ou donc n'allez pas me dire que
des pauvres peuvent posséder un vaisseau
pareil surtout que ça a l'air d'être un
bon vaisseau le vaisseau quand même
déposerait héros de parts il dit kai
lorraine que ses parents voilà cd simple
mariage crois je me souviens plus du
terme mais c'est faire ailleurs quoi en
gros sont des simples faire ailleurs
qu'ils auraient vendu de les ré pour de
l'eau je sais plus quoi et qui sont
morts sur dans une fosse commune sur de
jacou en plus elle a quand même un lien
avec le sabre laser qui lui montrent
cette vision ce n'est pas rien et le
sabre laser n'a jamais montré de vision
comme ça apparaît donc a forcément liens
que les skywalker peu importe le type
s'est pas forcément parental ya un lien
avec la forte avec la force et puissance
en elle tout ça etc
mais quand ils auraient n'a menti pour
moi il a menti vous êtes 37 à le penser
il a menti on ne connaît pas encore ses
parents
vous êtes 10% penser que les padres ont
forcément des gens importants alors
après je ne sais pas si ce sont vraiment
des gens importants mais ça ne peut pas
être de simples faire ailleurs
ray est une élue comme anakin elle n'a
pas de parents enfin que simplement une
mère et pas de plaire quoi comme anakin
vous êtes 10% de penser moi je suis
d'accord avec les 37 38 % voilà il
lorraine a menti enfin bref les parents
de ré c'est vraiment un gros mystère et
je vois qu entre snook et les parents
vous êtes vraiment vraiment très très
indécis et je sais que ryan johnson a
fait une réponse pour les parents de ré
comme quoi elle ne va pas soi-disant
corps découvert donc
donc voila quoi avez vous pensé du fait
que l'eia utilise à force ça c'est une
question aussi qui a fait beaucoup débat
et c'est une raison pour laquelle
beaucoup n'aiment pas star wars 8 en
fait juste pour ça et c'est dommage
les ja c'est la fille de anakin de dark
vador l'élu de la force
les ja et sa fille c'est normal qu'elle
ait des dispositions auprès de la force
et c'est à peu près l'utiliser au final
un petit peu avec le temps elle vieillit
tout ça est bien plus sage
elle commence à savoir s'en servir un
tout petit peu dans les moments de
danger et c'est que je trouve totalement
normal cela ne m'a pas choqué plus que
ça c'est une skywalker la force est en
elle vous êtes 33% le penser et moi je
suis d'accord avec ça abusé c'était
n'importe quoi on aurait dit du tg la
force est magique et voilà vous êtes 14%
de penser et je peux comprendre que
c'est choqué certains parce que ça a été
mal amenée à ce
un moment et pour moi c'est normal que
l'eia sache utiliser un petit peu la
force
elle est la fille de l'élu et la soeur
de lucky quand même aussi un très grand
jedi j'ai trouvé ça normal mais la scène
dans l'espace où elle revient est un peu
trop poussée et c'est justement à cause
de cette scène que les gens râlent et
que beaucoup n'aiment pas star wars 8
vous êtes 53% à le à le mentionner les
ja c'est utiliser la force et c'est vrai
que la scène était mal à mener voilà
j'arrête et dire voilà aussi l'accueil
lorraine oil and gas et lorraine n'ose
pas tirer sur le vaisseau de sa mère
dans le cockpit
j'ai envie de dire voilà mais les autres
vaisseaux tiers sur le cockpit et une
explosion voit la merde
elle est propulsée dans l'espace à cause
des vaisseaux alliés a key lorraine sauf
que du coup elle est censé mourir voilà
elle est censé mourir sauf que justement
ce n'est pas le cas elle revient elle
utilisa force pour sera menée sur le
vaisseau et tombe dans le coma a été mal
à mener c'est un état de dangers et puis
si ça m'a pas choqué plus que ça mais ça
a été mal fait ça aurait été mieux dans
une autre disposition plutôt atterrir
dans l'espace parce que c'est vrai que
dans l'espace voilà est-ce que star wars
8 est meilleur que star wars set ça
c'est une question qui me trottaient un
petit peu aussi dans la tête ça à savoir
7 a été beaucoup critiqué mais star wars
lui aussi alors lequel a été le meilleur
final vous êtes 80 % quand c'est que le
8 est meilleur après moi je pardonne
star wars est en même temps star wars ça
faisait 30 ans que ça existait tout le
monde était énormément hype et quand ils
ont appris qu'une nouvelle trilogie et
sortir que les gens étaient vraiment
très épais et attendait énormément
disney au tournant sachant qu'en plus
ces produits par disney donc les gens
étaient beaucoup plus réticents que ça
soit par rapport à george lucas star
wars est devait introduire la nouvelle
saga devait amener de nouvelles choses
en plus ils veulent faire de nouvelles
choses casser les codes des anciens star
wars essayé d'introduire une nouvelle
intrigue d'une nouvelle histoire et ça a
été compliqué surtout vu la hype que
tous les gens attendaient et maintenant
que star wars était sorti maintenant on
a nos
nouvelles bases et c'était beaucoup plus
simple pour star wars 8 je pense je
pense qu'aussi 6 3 8 a été beaucoup
critiqué pour ça parce que voilà savoir
s'il faut pas oublier que c'est la
liaison entre star wars 7 et star wars
9e malheureusement ce sont des films de
deux heures on peut pas avoir non plus
tout et c'est un condensé on va dire ça
a été vraiment réduit résumé mais bon
c'est vrai que star wars 8 était
vraiment bien je sais pas s'ils meurent
que le set mais j'ai au fond de moi je
dirais qu oui comment qualifieriez-vous
star wars 8 en trois mots et c'est la
dernière question [ __ ] les mecs je
vous dis en trois mots et attendre mi en
a quatre qui ont compris en fait
epic étonnant et mystérieux voilà c'est
ça que je voulais comme réponse très bon
film et racistes ont marqué ça c'est pas
en trois mots trois objectifs j'aurais
dû dire en trois adjectifs très bon film
il ya qu'un mot en fait techniquement et
avec une idée super alors ça c'est ceux
qui ont eu la flemme génial magnifique
splendide voix commençaient acceptant
star wars préféré humains et pique
humoristique
c'est vrai un gâchis entre nous ça ça
doit être un puriste force morts
explications tu as cru que c'était une
vidéo de queyries 78 tout quoi alors en
tout cas voilà donc n'hésitez pas à
répondre aux prochains prochains
sondages dans la description j'espère
que cette vidéo vous aura plu je voulais
vraiment tester quelque chose de nouveau
d'autres choses que les théories mais
évidemment les théories reste sain ça
restera toujours ses émissions principal
mais je voulais faire un quelques
concepts en plus et du coup je vous
laisse aller dans description pour faire
le prochain sondage je voulais analyser
vos réponses et j'espère que
ça vous aura plu n'hésitez pas à laisser
un petit like un petit commentaire à
vous abonner si ce n'est pas encore déjà
fait et que l'avionneur soit avec vous
[ __ ] c'est parti
[Musique]